So I'm actually just waiting for my husband
to come back from being inside the grocery store.
So what do I mean by Protection?
About the patriarchy?
So, biblical patriarchy.
I mean, my husband is my protector
number one. Um,
both physically,
which. There has been situations before we were married
that my husband physically protected me from other men.
Um, not that anything transpired or was crazy,
but, um, that.
That definitely was a thing.
Um, my husband protects me emotionally and spiritually.
He is able to correct me if I need corrected
in a gentle and in loving way.
My elders of my church protect me.
Um, if the. Were supposed to happen.
We can play the what if game all day long.
But in this case,
let's say my husband leaves me.
Um, my church
and my elders can hold him accountable for that
because he has also made membership vows to our church
and to. To become, um,
under the discipline of our church
if need be. And also,
I know for a fact that my elders
and the people of my church
would step up and be of a help to me in that time
if that was ever to happen,
which it's most likely not.
But you can play the what if game all day long.
And as a matter of fact,
is that no one.
No one is safe from the harshness, um,
of life and the.
The trials that life can bring.
No one is safe from that.
Not a woman who stays home
and not a woman who has a career.
I'd also like to add that I think it's misogynistic
to think that, um,
someone who's a homemaker
or someone who is a traditional wife.
Is not capable of figuring something out.
Or not capable of providing men for her family.
If that situation must ever happen.